oh jacqueline
coley this is so much fun because the
fourth of july
weekend celebration is about to be upon
us and that can only mean one thing in
my household
do you know how the ellis manor west
which is me and molly the wonder dog
celebrate fourth of july
uh i'm gonna guess that there is light
beer involved but i don't there
is a lot of i'm just gonna say it it's a
lot of white trash beer involved and
there's usually either some sort of john
mellencamp concert that i find
or a documentary about john cougar
mellencamp or
we usually cap it off with this
particular
movie that we're talking about today and
that would be the one the only
no no no not that movie where there's
something about to blow up earth in 1998
the other movie
michael bay's classic armageddon
it is listen to this are you sitting
down audience
38 on the tomato meter which puts it
squarely in rotten territory but there's
good news out there for all of us
americans and everyone else around the
world jacqueline
do you know what that is america
yeah but also america
and the audience on earth spoke
just as loud as that tomato meter they
have arrived at a 73
fresh audience score so there's a big
disparity with this movie between
the tomato meter and the audience were
between the critics and the people who
paid to see this movie and eat a lot of
popcorn during it and so
we're gonna get a lot of insight into
this movie not just with you and me and
our feelings about armageddon some
20-plus years later we're also gonna
welcome in a very special guest to the
show who
he's the co-host of the binge boys
podcast alongside hal rudnick who is
also a great friend of the show
he happens to be the most professorial
delinquent or
a delinquent who dabbles in
professionalism
and that would be lon harris lawn
welcome to the show i am so happy to
have you on here finally
and i have but one question for you and
your lovely dog taco
is rotten tomatoes wrong about
armageddon
raw tomatoes could not be more wrong
about armageddon 38
this is a travesty this is an insult to
america
this is an insult to the world this is
an insult to bruce willis the person
i i i we we have to do something about
this we have to discuss this
thank you so much for opening with that
fervor because jacqueline i feel like
lon thinks that this
score is an attack on all oil drillers
across the globe
to the rough neck nation i won't stand
for it
i am so excited about this episode so
folks light up your sparklers be safe
about it uh fire up the barbecue
and settle in for a nice discussion
about the film armageddon with us
jacqueline
here comes your challenge you put this
on me with tenet
so i get to fire back with maybe i'll
say this
this might be the easiest synopsis we've
ever done what is armageddon about
armageddon stars bruce willis as an oil
driller because we open the film
with meteor showers coming down and
people basically saying
oh my god the world is about to blow up
because there is
a world killer meteor coming
to destroy the earth and then they
decide well we're going to send our
fastest ships
up there to allah as a man would do
drill a hole in it
and blow it up but rather than get
astronauts trained in oil drilling
or sorry get astronauts trained in
drilling we're gonna send up
a bunch of not healthy crazy
probably um offenders
of some kind and send them up to the
moon to save the world and that is led
by bruce willis
he's along with ben affleck who's dating
his daughter played by liv tyler
we have a host of other great 90s
characters like owen wilson
and also steve buscemi sort of slumming
it in a michael bay movie
but you know they go up there to save
the day and they do
bruce willis has to stay behind because
they can't get the bomb off without him
and then the stephen tyler music plays
and diane warren wrote the song
but it didn't win the oscar and that's
armageddon
boom it can survive all the slings and
arrow smiths that are coming towards it
from critics because
it did phenomenal business around the
world when it came out it is still
re-watched not just on july 4th but
really any day of the year you put on
armageddon
you might have a lot of jokes at its
expense but you also might have a tear
welling up in your eye because of diane
warren's lyrics
for aerosmith's classic tune armageddon
you're really getting it well someone
who always gets us here is our producee
lucy
hello lucy you're on armageddon did you
get a chance
to re-watch this for the show last night
and it messed me up
about halfway through when bruce willis
is saying goodbye to liv tyler and they
have their little like
you're going to come back right dad i
was like
oh i started crying then and didn't
really stop
yeah it's so good it just hits you
different especially if you've had to
say goodbye to a parent it's like
armageddon this
this cheeseball blockbuster movie just
works on so many levels though
you did not know it could infiltrate and
that's probably one of the reasons why
it
endures so much and so look
lon you said that you think that the
tomato meter is absolutely abhorrently
wrong
with this you think that 38 is just
a little disgusting i'm just a small
tiny bit disgusted with it yeah
okay let's see if my co-pilot agrees
jacqueline you are
let's face it the han to my chewy so you
would be like
you would be the bruce willis to my owen
wilson do you think that rotten tomatoes
is wrong
i'm gonna say 38 is a bit harsh but i
don't want to give
michael bay any credit so i'm not gonna
say
basically i'm like i'm not saying that
the rotten tomatoes
is right but i understand
i understand i understand why they were
like
we just can't with this anymore but i i
i have fun with this movie this movie
has a lot i love a good montage
and this movie knows how to do them well
as does the director like you mentioned
michael bay graded montage is
great at those up close shots of
billowing trench coats and
slow-motion walks and this if it was
fresh like lon
and i think it is i think ron dominus is
wrong too by the way i think it's closer
to the audience score
i can see this movie landing at 60.01
percent
and i'd be happy with that just get it
into freshville because michael bay
deserves another fresh movie is he
my favorite director no do i like what
he did with transformers
not at all but i love the rock and i
love 13 hours so i think he deserves
another fresh film on his resume
it might as well be armageddon but while
we're here yapping the critics have
already spoken and
for more on what they were saying at the
time of the film's release way back when
when we were all so young in 1998
we go to our expert review curation
manager here at rotten tomatoes
mr tim ryan tim take it away
with tim there's an old saying that
movies come in pairs and the late 1990s
was a particularly weird time where
a bunch of thematically similar movies
were being released around the same time
some notable examples include two movies
about track star
steve prefontaine which is pre-fontaine
in 1997
and without limits in 1998 and two
animated films about insects both
ants and a bug's life were released
within weeks of each other
in the fall of 1998. of course nothing
could possibly compare to the
four body switch comedies like father
like son vice versa 18 again and big
that were released in 1987 and 1988.
there were two films about global
catastrophes in 1998 armageddon came out
less than two months after deep impact
which at 45
on the tomato meter didn't exactly set
the world on fire no pun intended but it
spent more time with his characters and
benefited from
morgan freeman's central performance in
the case of armageddon the critics that
liked it felt it was like a roller
coaster with its visceral thrills and
big special effects triumphing over its
plot and characters but most reviewers
felt it was too noisy
too long too predictable and the
characters were particularly thin
it's at 38 on the tomato meter with 122
reviews but it does have a 73
audience score so what did the critics
have to say in a rotten review
roger ebert from the chicago sun times
wrote here it is at last
the first 150 minute trailer armageddon
is cut together like its own highlights
take almost any 30 seconds at random and
you'll have a tv
ad the movie is an assault on the eyes
the ears the brain common sense
and the human desire to be entertained
no matter what they're charging to get
in
it's worth more to get out however in a
fresh review david edelstein of slate
wrote
along with the rest of the audience i
jumped when i was meant to jump
laughed when i was meant to laugh and
swallowed a lump in my throat when i was
meant to feel moved
the rotten tomatoes critic's consensus
for armageddon reads lovely to look at
but about as intelligent as the asteroid
that serves as the movie's antagonist
armageddon slickly sums up the cinematic
legacies of producer jerry bruckheimer
and director michael bay
so anyway mark and jacqueline i can't
wait to hear what you guys have to say
about this movie
and i don't want to miss a thing
oh tim sounded like he was saying
that reference to the airsmith song
against his will but that's why
he is the most professional out of any
of us thank you tim for that yeah
that was the thing that i i looked at a
lot of critic reviews of this movie
last night in prepping for this episode
and that was their biggest complaint it
wasn't even the science loopholes it was
just
this movie is so loud and this movie is
just such a
big music video that's all tied together
and i just i get that complaint but i
also
that might be one of the reasons why i
have so much fun watching it so we're
gonna get into all of that and more when
we talk about armageddon and the movie
scenes in particular
let's get back to 1998 right now with a
little help from our friends
brian cue the music
[Music]
you know juan jacqueline this is that
movie that if i could watch this film
with one other person in a movie theater
that human being
unfortunately would not be either one of
you two it would be neil degrasse tyson
just because i would love to watch his
head
explode trying to figure out how you
could even rectify
putting this this
hooligan movie that is just such a
scientific fraud on the big screen
juan we get past that though because we
have such a good time watching it
do you have a scene that just leaps out
at you from armageddon that
explains why you have such an affinity
for this and why you think the movie
deserves to be fresh i mean i love the
fact that it
is fast and loose with the science i
feel like we get so many of those movies
where it's like this is what space is
really like and this is how exacting it
is and how careful you have to be
and how you know there's a lot of those
apollo 13 movies like
if this screw is one-eighth looser
then we blow up on re-entry you know you
have to get all the angles of the math
exactly right
it's like refreshing to watch a movie
where ben affleck is like
i bet that we could just jump this buggy
uh over this canyon we don't need to do
a calculation
we're on an asteroid there's some
gravity like even when scientists
and doctors talk in this movie
everything always gets reduced
immediately like
nobody says anything sciency the entire
time even when it's just nasa guys
sitting around
they're like so it's big it's like
that's the south of texas like i don't
think that's how
doctors talk what is this thing it's an
asteroid sir
how big are we talking sir our best
estimate is 97.6 billion it's the size
of texas mr president
yes sir dan we didn't see this thing
coming
well our object collision budget's a
million dollars that allows us to track
about three percent of the sky
and begging your pardon sir but it's a
big ass sky all right so yeah i think
those are the moments that i i love the
most where it's just like
they're they're just gonna do the thing
and it's just physically possible
because they
because they want it to be like when the
when the entire russian space station is
exploding like
pretty sure that would happen quickly
and you'd all be dead it wouldn't be
like
one little compartment at a time so you
had time to like run away
and that's also the entire movie
jacqueline is you have
like you said so eloquently in your
synopsis of this film is that
the premise of the film is hey look we
can either we have one of two options
here we can either train some astronauts
in how to do some drilling on an
asteroid or
we can just have people who know how to
drill into
cavernous rocks on earth and send them
up and train them
in the art of astronauting and then
everything is going to be fine and we're
going to save the world
that way and so given the context that
this is a
entirely ridiculous premise what is the
scene to you
that says and i'm going to give you an
option here because i know you're not as
high on this movie as lon and i do you
have a scene that illustrates why
you can say this movie is too low on the
tomato meter or do you have a scene as
to why
it is as low as it is i'll give it to
like this is a scene where like i get it
and i enjoy it very much
i i i will say again because even though
i'm not like
this is the greatest movie ever i do
like it and i think i actually have it
on
on dvd and i know i had it at one point
on vhs so like i'm not gonna pretend
like i don't like armageddon i was
entertained watching it again
you know russell crowe didn't need to
ask but the scene that sort of i think
encompasses why i really like it is that
it is these characters like they're just
so
stupid but so entertaining and the
montage
when they get hairy and like
basically say to him okay come to nasa
and he's just like these idiots are not
going to be able to do it
let me go get my ragtag groups and they
basically go throughout
the united states looking for these
people all they got to do is drill
that's it no space walking no crazy
astronaut stuff
just grill how many men were you
planning on taking up there
we're sending up two shuttles two teams
if i do this i'm going to want to take
my own men
you got it and then you got like one of
them like you got owen wilson i think
like riding on the horse you got
rockhound being like that girl
told me she was 18. yeah they do the
they totally do the getting the heist
crew together
like you son of a even though
they don't have to they just showed them
together and all bruce willis did was
get on a helicopter like
why are they rounding them up across the
us how do they even have
time exactly but it's so funny and i
think what also it is too
is like these are two sort of things and
it encapsulates that scene when they're
agreeing to do it
is when they have their list of demands
and like one of them is like we want to
know who killed jfk
i just think that like stuff like that
is just so stupid
and in no way cinematic but how are you
not entertained
how are you not entertained and it's
really great because
as the story progresses it's those
moments that make you sort of love them
a bit
is the reason why um you
feel for them and are invested in them
even more than saving the world
you find it endearing because it it's
almost like you go back to the original
bert reynolds the longest yard where
it's or or even bad news bears or it
feels like a sports movie
in that scene that jacqueline's talking
about where look they go to bruce willis
character nasa goes to bruce willis
character they say hey
there's this rock and you're the guy
you're the best or you're the number one
ranked oil driller on earth
and so you have to get your crew
together
and he is now kind of realizing that the
ball is in his court and that he has
some power here and so just uniting this
ragtag group of nerdy wells for this
mission
is one of the most fun parts and i would
throw in there one of my favorite scenes
is
the night before they really have to get
locked in and actually go
do this mission is they all just go out
and have this crazy night and
there's a fist fight there's a brawl at
a at a
place of ill repute there's exotic
dancing going on there's
there's one dollar bill's making it rain
they're drinking too much they're
getting into trouble
and you just love watching them interact
as a crew but there is this tinge
of emotional weight to it because they
know that this is probably the last
night that they ever get to party on
earth like this
yeah yeah i think one of the things that
makes this movie stand out especially in
like a modern context is that you do
spend a lot of time with these guys
before the main story kicks in movies
are
in such a relentless hurry i think a lot
of times we kind of gloss over that you
get one or two scenes with the crew
and then we're like into the mission
into the story like let's get to space
and this movie it's like 45 minutes of
them just oil drilling and training and
getting to know each other and it does
pay off once they're on the asteroid
does lon harris get emotional at any
point
watching armageddon and if so what is
the moment for you what is the scene for
you
that says hey this is more than just
shoving a bunch of popcorn in our face
and ignoring science uh yeah i mean i
think listen
the end of the movie is it's well done
it's it is what it is it's
it's sweeping it's over the top like
this is the michael bay where
you know he's he's using the mtv editing
and sort of
modern techniques and his aesthetic was
very like 90s
but he's got he's got the soul of like
an old
showman you know like he was doing pearl
harbor after this
he's got a very like sentimental old
hollywood
side to him underneath all of the like
tracking shots where you go like
underneath the guy
and swoop around will smith and martin
lawrence or whatever and i think that
comes out
in the in the climax of armageddon when
it really is about
you know this this sacrifice that the
bruce willis character is uh
you know is making and and the the real
human costs that it has back on earth
daddy hi gracie
bag honey grace i know i promised you i
was coming home
i don't understand looks like i'm gonna
have to break that promise
[Music]
i am i lied to you too
when i told you that i didn't want to be
like you
because i am like you jacqueline that
scene
for me gets me every time and i think i
would have said this even before
you know my family lost our patriarch is
that that scene for whatever reason
is at the end when we realize that we
have this bomb and we successfully put
this bomb in the heart of the asteroid
and so we can blow it up
the problem is that we need somebody to
go down there and trigger it and if you
trigger the bomb you can't just do it
remotely
uh for whatever technical reason didn't
happen correctly so now we got to go
down there we actually have to press the
explode button on the bomb like we're
wiley coyote
and hope that it works and so bruce
willis
and ben affleck have this sort of
switcheroo because bruce knows that even
though
he's not crazy about his little girl
coincidentally played by
liv tyler who is the daughter of stephen
tyler who's singing the song
yeah he says look i don't like you but i
know it's gonna break my little girl's
heart and that you you two are truly in
love and i accept that so i'm gonna do
the old switcheroo
and i'm going down to detonate this
thing and i disagree with your read mark
ellis
you think he really doesn't like ben
affleck and he's just doing it
for liv tyler's sake i think that he was
a fan of that and he never was able to
say it okay i don't know man
i don't know if this guy if if harry
stamper bruce willis character had his
way
on earth the it okay i'll put it like
this it took a freaking asteroid
threatening the very existence of the
human species to get bruce willis to
even want to shake ben affleck's
hand if he was picking his daughter up
for prom he
had he'd had some shocking news he felt
very upset that morning that he hadn't
been told about their relationship
before
felt a little betrayed felt stung by
betrayal
he got a little hot under the collar he
got a little upset i'm confident that
would have blown over had there not been
an asteroid they would have made up
that there would have been a mutual
understanding i don't i don't think you
could fake the funk
at the end that way like i don't think
bruce willis is a big faker
and he's just pretending to see this guy
as he calls him son
when he's going back up into the into
the ship for the last okay i'll give you
that
he does say something he says i see his
uh take care of her son or whatever like
he
he means it he feels that he's just
listen he's a he's a roughneck he's an
oil man
these these emotions don't come easily
to uh to
to a bruce willis he's gotta he's gotta
build up to it and a whole generation of
men who will not embrace therapy is born
i agree with you that um
this was probably him you know showing
emotion because basically
it's literally the end of the world
that's the only time it's allowed
it's the only time it's allowed billy
bob thornton never sheds a single tear
he's facing down the end of the world
the whole time i mean
also too i did like the fact that he did
it like this was just
like i will say for how stupid it is
let's be honest first of all the fact
that he's able to rip a patch
off of a space suit that's supposed to
keep you alive no matter what because
this is some real
top notch we can build two planes that
can
fly faster than any other planes can fly
but then patches
done um yeah i give it to you on that
one
also i just want to give a little shout
out though to jason isaacs who shows up
at the very early part
um with billy bob thornton who's sort of
leading the nerds
there's the nerd patrol who come up with
this genius idea that the people of nasa
hate so much that they wrote literally
like an entire
like entry about how stupid it is
they're like this will never happen we
would never be able to even build a bomb
big enough to
blow this thing up anyway jason isaacs
coming with his whole like
i don't think that a man who failed
physics at
mit should be the person that the
president is
taking advice but i was like oh the
british shade i love him
so much he's my favorite thing in the
very first parts of this movie
him and shout out to random eddie
griffin
because i still want to be a part of the
casting session
that michael bay had to say we're going
to get eddie griffin
yeah i feel like that must have been
special or he must have been like i want
there to be one new yorker who's
reacting and it needs to be
specifically eddie griffin eddie griffin
huge shout out to eddie griffin and
folks hurry up and mark curry mark curry
yeah
yeah yeah mr cooper mr yeah the cab
driver yeah if
if you all have not seen undercover
brother we should do a run tonight is
this wrong episode about undercover
brother because that is a
criminally underrated
yeah so look this movie billy bob
thornton is is one of the things i
wanted to bring up here because when you
talk about actors and performances in
this movie
bruce willis does a great job being that
that alpha male that that movie star
lead where you're only allowed to cry if
it's the end of the world or if a famous
athlete is retiring
ben affleck and lyft i would do a great
job as the young couple who are in love
who have to go do something in their
part but they still love each other and
this only seals their bond even more
but billy bob thornton is tasked with
really a dual role in this movie because
lon you brought up apollo 13.
billy bob thornton has to be that ed
harris voice of reason and calmness in
the room
at nasa when you're monitoring the
situation
but he also has to be like who bill
pullman was
in independence day because he has given
so many lines
that unless their hands could have sunk
this movie
because they just would have rolled off
so cheesy or
just implausible and as ridiculous as
the movie itself
is billy bob thornton would not be my
first round draft pick to play ahead of
nasa
but he would be if you said we need that
head of nasa to be able to relate all of
this
scientific mumbo jumbo to us the regular
audiences of the world
i want billy bob thornton being that guy
to explain it to me
yeah yeah there's a lot of movies that
try to do also this character who's like
he's like a bureaucrat but he's also a
cowboy like it was
just jeffrey d morgan just did it in
rampage a few years ago
where he's like look at his belt buckle
and his revolver he doesn't do things
the way
other guys do and billy bob has that
exact same role here it's like what if
the head of nasa but also
texan and he nails it it's it's not
over the top it doesn't feel cheesy or
too much it just feels like
well yeah this guy's from texas and see
something
it makes sense there's an entire like
like going to
to the sort of like junior astronaut
program was like a legit texas thing i
can say as a girl that was raised in
texas it was something
that i was not necessarily about but
tons of my kids they used to do like
advertisements for it like on saturday
morning cartoons to be like you can go
to the nasa junior space program which
was basically just
pay a bunch of money to go pretend
you're an astronaut for space camp
yes yes my only point of reference on
this was the film space campus yeah
well exactly and it's exactly that
except for it's much more
of a commercialistic endeavor with no
choi with no hopes of ever making kids
smart enough to do you don't know
it's worth it it doesn't accidentally
blast you it's worth the money if you
get to go in that thing that like that
like weird like agrocrack jumbotron
thing where they just strap you in and
just moves you all around and
differently oh my god
i don't know if their insurance would
would hold that i think the best you got
to do would be to do those like zero
gravity like
air thingies okay now you can do in like
glendale for
150 bucks like those those are at the
mall now yeah
like again this is the 90s kids we were
doing the best though
freeze-dried ice cream you get to try
some of that some of that freeze-dried
ice cream
back in my day go-karts didn't have seat
belts
yeah one thing i was going to say about
arigato is in addition to we mentioned
jason isaacs we mentioned billy bob
thornton
i feel like every speaking role in this
movie went to some
notable character actor there's no
udokir
is the psychiatrist peter stormere is
the russian
cosmonaut william fickner is the guy the
the the
you know on the shuttle keith david is
the general they have to battle with
back in dc
like everybody's famous seriously also
freaking um
buscemi again slumming it but slumming
it in the best
possible way where it's just like i'm
gonna be slightly pedophilic
and creepy yeah and then i go crazy for
the second half of the movie
full of crazy people awesome
also if we're going to go ahead and make
the the sort of like
jump or bridge between 80s cheesies
movie
cheesy movies that did not get the right
tomato meter rating with 90 cheesy
movies that did not get the right tomato
meter rating the
kernel of the the i guess it's the
the freedom or whichever one is the one
that goes down the one that ben affleck
is on
uh that colonel the one that like turns
around it's like
we're all gonna die that is the bad guy
from roadhouse that is marcus teague for
folks that don't know
the guy that patrick swayze ends up like
like ripping his neck the throat the
throat
dude that dude that dude
i would also as producer lucy and i were
talking pre-show
uh will patton is also great in
everything
he's the assistant coach and remember
the titans and then he also shows up
here and so
i think that's one of the reasons why
critics at the time or even now
would watch this movie and think this is
just one giant music video billboard is
because
it's a new famous person every minute
that is introduced in this film and they
have a couple lines and then sometimes
they stick around other times they just
get out of the movie
the rest of the for the rest of the
running time but you just
it's so fun to watch them lean into it
because if they do not commit to it
then you really don't have any semblance
of a movie but everybody goes all out
here that's what i love about this film
and it doesn't take itself nearly as
seriously
as the other comet movie that tim ryan
referenced at the time which was deep
impact because
this was one of those things 98 it was
like 1992 with columbus movies where you
had competing movies
and there's a reason why armageddon is
still the more
favored one as far as audiences go it's
interesting to look at
deep impact has a higher tomato meter
score but a much
lower audience score and they got too
nerdy with it
yeah they just got too nerdy but they
also there's a nice emotional scene at
the end of deep impact but
even though that movie took itself more
seriously i still get the emotional
weight in armageddon more
yeah deep impact is trying to do that
thing of like it's a it's realistic it's
like what would
what would really happen it's trying to
i don't know if i want to say it's
realistic but it's trying to be a what
would really happen
if this happened in the world and
armageddon is just the complete 180 like
how can we make this a goofy intense
exciting
thrill machine without any regard for
what would really
happen in the actual world and i don't
know if this movie had a good tomato
meter rating
um if somebody wants to look it up but
greenfield
or greenfell the the jared uh
greenland there you go that recently
came out
i watched this one and i remember it was
really funny like the publicist like
emailed me she's like so what did you
think i was like i think i liked it
better when it was deep impact but i'm
not gonna lie this is the best thing
butler has done in a long time
and i think the reason why is it
threaded that needle a little better
with the emotion the bizarrity the
stupidity
but then also like the reality because
that one was less about like let's go
save the world as
and it was much more like deep impact
where like we just need to hide
and like burrow down deep and just the
realities of doing that like the reason
why jared butler and his family get
saved is because he's a structural
engineer and so they're like yeah the
world is going to be over when we're
done
and that move is getting a sequel some
something that neither one of these two
have
got it's 78 percent certified fresh
there you go
there's only one really like big i
thought it was going to be much more
action drift there's only like one big
action sequence in greenland where all
the like the little
meteors are falling like it's really
much more of like just like a thriller
about
you gotta it almost has that that
walking dead like the real
the real horror is exactly but that's
still
action to me even though it's not like a
big action like explosion sequence
the idea of like can we get here let's
go get the insulin and like doing that
sort of like we got to like to do
you know like right the connective
tissue between greenland and armageddon
is is you have that that leading action
star where if i was watching armageddon
but it didn't have
unfortunately maybe that's just how us
audiences are trained now especially in
1998
if if you see this movie and it doesn't
have people you recognize
it this is direct to to vhs at the time
the fact that bruce willis is on the
movie poster the fact that we've been
following this guy in adventures in
exploding buildings
and on wings of airplanes and running
around new york city with sam jackson
we believe this guy anything that this
guy's doing
we lend him credibility and so i think
that that is one of the most important
things of this movie is that
you can take a lot of films there's a
lot of movies out there folks and i hate
to say the star wars nerds
there's a lot of stuff that doesn't
scientifically check out in star wars
the explosions don't make noise in outer
space sorry to break that to you
and so if you really want to go down
that rabbit hole as to well that's not
scientifically
pretty much every even gravity which is
a movie that took itself so seriously
has things that don't necessarily check
every box as far as reality goes
when you're in outer space and yeah
progress tyson hates that one too
yeah he probably likes armageddon more
than gravity because at least armageddon
knew what it was and the the music video
quality of this movie is something else
i wanted to touch on before we move to
behind the scenes
is because this movie is an assault on
your senses
with explosions with great cheesy
and i say that in the same sentence
one-liners but there's also a heavy dose
of rock music particularly from one of
the all-time greats aerosmith
does that up the quality of the movie
for you or does that make it feel more
like a commercial
uh i mean yeah i i think that it uh
i i don't feel like this movie looks
like a music video i think that this
movie looks like
peak vintage michael bay like this is
the michael bay
style and it's it's quick cutting but
it's it's all to like
draw you in and draw you into the
intensity of the moment like even if you
can't see exactly what it is that you're
seeing
it's not just quick cut to like quick
cutting looks cool or gives you that
cool
music video effect it's like oh my god
ben affleck's got to get out of this
this you know shuttle right now it's
about to explode it's like
getting me building and building the
intensity around that moment i don't
know if that's like a music video
which i think it was just like flash and
spectacle
i don't i don't know it feels more
directed to me what michael bay is doing
having said that
there certainly are some sequences of
the movie where it is just like
you know you can tell that he's a guy
that had like a commercial in a music
video background
it does feel like titanic though
jacqueline because you have that scene
early in the movie where you hear this
the the sort of orchestral arrangement
that that hints
at i don't want to miss a thing the song
by aerosmith and then it comes back at
the end
a lot of the same way the titanic does
that where
you have these notes of celine dion but
then you really get the full power of it
at the end and so if you're talking
about songs that were companions to
big profile movie releases that really
just tugged at your heart strings
you could go with what is it up where we
belong with officer and a gentleman
i i put this on a par with that
yeah i mean look i think that
it's a shame i went back and looked and
the song that
uh diane warren and this lost to because
aerosmith
will hate to admit it but their
literally most successful song is a song
that they didn't even write and didn't
get the majority of the money for
uh diane warren did um but she ended up
losing
for the prince of egypt which don't get
me wrong it's whitney houston and mariah
carey singing it which is not a bad
thing but come on this thing was like
the hit and it's unfortunate because it
just follows along in this line
of people not really caring about those
rock
ballads that we all think of but i don't
think
academy voters do it and i don't think
uh up where we belong one as well
either no it's just one yeah it's just
really interesting these pop songs that
we
so associate with these movies and we
are
like this is the thing that we think of
when we think of this movie and it's a
grand sweeping moment
usually doesn't get rewarded in the end
but i do agree it's like absolutely
incredible
and it is actually a testament to
michael bay's music video
history he did the meatloaf video
um i would do anything for love but i
won't do that
so the man knows how to set some stuff
to some cinematic
uh rock music but it's his commercial
background that i think belies some of
his directing techniques in this one
in like not a good way because this is
literally a commercial for the world is
going to end
that's that's it because look folks i
don't fancy myself an actor at all
despite what the carfax or bud light
commercials of my youth would tell you
the one thing there's two dream roles
that i have in a movie someday i just
want to be a newscaster in a movie just
because i
i just think it'd be fun just to like
like you know set the movie up like a
hurricane it's fast approaching
but i also really want to be like like
again
going back to billy bob thornton or
anybody in charge in this movie
the reveal of the threat of
how devastating this could be that is
just
as an actor that's got to be the thing
that you just you sink your teeth into
and you're like oh i cannot wait to
deliver this line in a big blockbuster
i get to tell the president that this
thing is the size of texas
that is one of my favorite takeaways
from this movie is just how well those
lines that could have fallen flat
just continue to engross us
in this movie parting shots as far as
movie talk
in this segment goes i'll start with you
alon then go to
um for your your sort of final summation
as to why you feel the way you do about
armageddon
i i mean to me i i think it's just it's
the relentlessness it's once they're in
space
it's like there's over an hour left in
the movie and it's just
non-stop and it doesn't just like most
movies would build towards
the climax this movie is just it's all
climax i think that's kind of like what
roger ebert was saying but i mean it in
a good way
like they they have to they have to stop
on the russian space station to get fuel
and ah now it's going to explode
like oh we landed wrong so you guys are
over there and you gotta drive over to
us and
it's just adding complication layer
under layer until it's like it's almost
a parody of a thriller there's a moment
where the team is dismantling the
nuclear weapon because of course there's
also a nuclear weapon that gets
set off too early of course and uh steve
buscemi is just there along the
sidelines like
do a good job do a good job do a good
job and it's like it's we're
almost edging into like a a
abram zucker parody of this genre we're
like
just over the line before this becomes
top secret and like i don't know i kind
of love that about it they just go for
it
i love that you referenced abram zucker
because there's another abrams not
abraham's with the h but j.j abrams one
of the credited writers
on armageddon so and remember that yeah
before we move on is this
would that would you consider this to be
michael bay's greatest achievement in
filmmaker do you have another movie
i i feel like the bad boys the rock
armageddon like that
trilogy that's that's peak bay like
that's the man's
that's the band's greatest work to date
i i think the rock is probably my
personal favorite out of those three but
i i think you could you could sort of
take your pick like i i think those
three represent
the pinnacle of venus yeah as our as our
fresh ketchup crew knows i
i put the rock and point break is the
two greatest action movies of the 90s
but also give a huge shout out again i
thought 13 hours was just
fantastic filmmaking so uh jacqueline
coley
your parting shot for armageddon
well i'll say this um even though you
didn't ask me i actually
think that the rock is michael bay's
greatest and i say that knowing that
i'm betraying the culture by not picking
bad boys but
[Laughter]
the writing that was in the rock was
rewritten some credited some uncredited
by
none other than aaron sorkin and quentin
tarantino
and it's the only movie of his i think
that's currently fresh
or one of one of the few that's
currently fresh so i actually stand by
that one
look it's not a good movie
at least at this point in michael bay's
career he kind of cared
so he cared somewhat i think for for
story and plot he gave us that
daddy daughter thing and didn't give us
things like hey a 17 year old can bang a
15 year old and it's it's legal like
a 19 year old can bang a 17 year old and
it's legal like at least he was moving
past
that and he cared enough to give that
little bit of
i would say care to the story and plot
but if you want to turn off your brain
for an hour and a half on fourth of july
i can't think of a better way to do it
honestly
there's not very many so unless you're
going to watch illegally blonde red
white and
and blonde right or you just do that you
can't turn your brain off but hbo always
does their run of john adams which i can
sometimes get sucked into as well
let's move on to behind the scenes
because there is some stuff to talk
about with the making of armageddon and
how it all
came together and how we feel about it
some two plus decades later brian
cue the music
[Music]
you folks listening have no idea how how
what an ego stroke it is just be able to
command someone to cue up music and they
do it and you just feel so powerful for
that hour that you're doing
the podcast look the one name that we
didn't touch on a lot in movie talk
is ben affleck because i think according
to
michael bay slash jerry bruckheimer i i
think bruckheimer
maybe wanted bay uh wanted affleck in
this movie more than bay did and so
i think early iterations this movie they
really thought that they could have done
even without that character entirely and
if you want to know
that this movie was made in 1998 look no
further than ben affleck's character's
name
aj frost if that isn't the most boy band
name i've ever heard
on in the face of human history then
that would
surprise me um when you look at this
movie
and you talk about how it came together
it's so interesting to see even the cast
interviewed about it now
it's not one of those films that they
shy away from talking about this is not
a
john cusack refusing to talk about con
air situation
even billy bob thornton likes talking
about this movie he celebrates this
movie i think that they're so enthralled
with the fact that they managed to pull
it off
at all and make it the blockbuster that
it was
that they look back on it very fondly
and so
michael bay and the huge box office that
this was
inevitably lon this movie is the reason
why we continue to get michael bay
movies and why we got transformers
movies so
did we shoot ourselves in the artistic
foot by
supporting this film because of the
transformers franchise that followed
i mean i definitely think this is one of
those scenarios where we invested a
filmmaker with a lot of
power and then i don't know once they
amassed all of this power
did they use it in responsible ways like
i i don't know like
somebody somebody in a position to give
michael bay
practical advice and tips might have
helped us during his
transformers era when i do feel like
it's it's the charm gets sucked away
like all
of the all of the spectacle and the
intensity and the length and the aiming
for
epicness and the kitchen sink approach
all that
stayed but he lost the the charm of it
and the humanity that it had and stuff
like the rock and
uh armageddon and so now it just becomes
endless
and humorless and you know that's how
you get a transformers for
ironically jacqueline the most human
tones that i feel in the transformers
movies are from optimus prime
yeah i wonder if that was like voice
over and like bae was too busy like
you know salivating over an explosion
look
i don't want to discount too as like
this morning you're reading about
other hollywood people who had
notoriously bad reputations and you
realize like whatever the bad reputation
was it was probably
a bit worse but there's like a litany of
people that worked with michael bay
talking about how he was on set
and a little i think it was megan fox
went on to say he was a little tyrant
or worse like a mini hitler which i'm
not endorsing that kind of uh
epitaph for anyone but i do think it
can't be discounted to say like
when you get lauded and told that you're
amazing and very early in your career
get to work with the likes of george
lucas
and um spike jones and david fincher and
because of that sort of like nepotistic
um boys club get told how great you are
and never really push through because of
any actual accomplishments but just your
proximity to greatness
i don't know if that's gonna be the best
thing for building the type of person
who is gonna
be the best to work with on set and i'm
not basing this on my assessment i'm
basing it on the assessment of the
people that have worked with him and
what they've said
so um i think it's a good thing he
stepped back a bit
from directing yeah famously uh filed
storyboards for george lucas earlier
in his career let's talk about the ben
affleck though because again
during the making of the movie they
might have thought that ben affleck was
just an afterthought but
could you also argue that this movie is
the reason why ben affleck became the
movie star
that we still revere him as his career's
had some ups and downs since then but
he was great in the the kevin smith
movies he was great in goodwill hunting
but
is armageddon lon the reason why ben
affleck is still
known as ben affleck today yeah i mean i
think
you you don't get modern ben affleck
without a movie or two like this
at this moment you know like goodwill
hunting
chasing amy you know a lot of indie hits
you know a lot of a lot of popular films
are sort of the indoor kids but
this this and and you know like the a
few movies that followed were
that's what sold him to mainstream
america is like he's gonna be
you know a real a real force in movies
beyond you know being the bomb in
phantoms so
he definitely was yeah definitely the
bobby fantas and i mean i don't think it
was necessarily like
justice but but it was looking i'm
looking at his filmography it was it was
a lot of this
like i think it was pearl harbor
slash j law
like yes i mean right jennifer was like
a big step
as well and you know i mean like boiler
room shakespeare love like he popped up
in some
some stuff that had a little heat but i
think when he did
i think when he did um daredevil he was
a star
but i i don't know i think it's pearl
harbor pearl harbor was when it was like
this has been affleck another michael
bay movie another michael baby
it's still his fault so i'm definitely
saying it's michael bay's fault yeah and
and
and you can you can rightfully criticize
michael bay for pearl harbor
and a lot of his movies but there are
even scenes in pearl harbor like the
first
like when they're playing baseball then
all the planes are flying overhead i
still i
i feel i feel my stomach drop when i see
it and so
the guy does know how to make if not an
entire movie
cohesive he does really know how to make
scenes
that hit you emotionally like the end of
armageddon
as far as affleck goes you could say the
same thing for owen wilson in a sense
because michael bay was a huge fan of
bottle rocket
and that's why owen wilson got cast in
this movie and a fun behind-the-scenes
story is that owen wilson
was late like an hour and a half he was
late to set his first day
shooting armageddon and michael bay
reportedly told him
he just pulled him aside and he said hey
you know i did the rock with sean
connery
sean connery was never late once and as
the story goes owen wilson was never
late again
to the set of armageddon juan i know
that
one of the fun gems when you go back and
watch this movie is somehow it's a
criterion collection movie
for whatever reason and you get it
it's a touchstone disney thing that
their deal with is true their deal with
criterion was you can have
some of the films from the archive that
you want but you've got to put the
michael bay touchstone movies on
criterion as well
because famously the rock that's how the
rock and armageddon ended up with
criteria well the rock deserves it but
but even bay himself is kind of like
wondering during the director's
commentary
why is this a criterion movie but i know
that you're a huge fan
of the commentary what is your favorite
sort of like behind the scenes
tidbit from armageddon there's a very
famous story that's that comes up on the
commentary about ben
affleck behind the scenes that was
basically questioning
we mentioned it already the entire
premise of this film like it makes
it doesn't make sense that you would
send up roughnecks who are good at
oil drilling to space instead of taking
guys who are already prepped to go to
space
and training them here's how to work a
drill and they do
i like that they i think maybe in
reaction to affleck's comments they put
this line in the movie there is one
scene
where they have bruce willis say this to
believe about thor like like
look it's a delicate art and a science
drilling you can't just teach
i can't i'm uh i'm a conductor i have to
be there myself i only trust my crew and
billy butler and just like okay i accept
this
i accept this at face value uh it so
yeah
i like that even even on set some of the
same criticisms we would say come up
with in the
honest trailers right writer's room
we're already coming up like this
this is a weird plan jaclyn any any last
behind-the-scenes
nuggets of wisdom um just shout out to
animal crackers
i will say wow they made a replacement
they
really not only was that ingenious
product placement
but i know the
the girls of 1998 some of them were like
drive me off to the sunset with animal
crackers
see animal crackers definitely was
responsible for some for some teen
shenanigans
i would i would sign off on that if the
animal crackers were
frosted animal cookies because those are
delicious and still
my go-to topping if i ever happen across
a pink berry and i have a hankering um
this is not those are definitely cookies
you don't get the cracker cookie
disparity which
the entire dialogue of the sequence is
built around
no i i i understand what ben and liv
were going for i also understand my
history as a chubby kid where if you
offer me a cracker versus a cookie
the cracker is going to be sitting on
that table for a long time
because i'm going cookie every day twice
on sundays
look this movie it's a very fun movie to
talk about it is a very fun movie to
revisit and i do actually have a trivia
question
that producer lucy's going to help me
answer because
i don't know the answer to this trivia
question juan as you know i usually at
least know what the answer is or i have
it right there in front of me yeah i was
going to say somebody's usually put it
on a card for you so i'm going
to ask you and jaclyn and y'all can team
up with this if you want
what is the difference between an
asteroid a comet
and a meteor go i know
a comet is a asteroid and a meteor are
both just
rock a comet is a ball of rock and gas
so that's that's that's one difference
right there and that it's got a it's got
a trail behind it because it's
it's leaking gas as it flies i'm gonna
guess that an
asteroid is before it inches the ash
that's exactly what i was gonna hear i
feel like a meteor is once it's coming
to hit earth it becomes a meteor and
then a meteorite
and an asteroid is when it's still in
space can i tell you all something even
if you're completely wrong
that was just as logical as anything in
armageddon and i believe that
you sold it to get the expert behind the
scenes analysis we go to producey lucy
were they correct
your answers combined i think are pretty
correct the short answer
is an asteroid is a small rocky object
that orbits the sun
asteroids are smaller than the planet
but they are larger than the
pebble-sized objects we call
meteoroids a meteor is what happens when
a small piece of an asteroid or comet
called a meteoroid burns up upon
entering earth's atmosphere
so i think y'all are right yeah i agree
i was gonna say i was gonna say uh star
like material for a comment which i
guess i'm not letting you get away with
starlight material yeah yes that's
that's all it is what it is
a starlight material yeah it's a ball of
rock and gas
that's right the comet is a body of ice
rock and dust
that can be several miles in diameter
and orbits the sun so i think comets and
asteroids are kind of the same thing
neil degrassi tyson are you listening to
our podcast please chime in
to email us and tell us if we're right
or wrong he's got like eight pages of
notes already
i'm sure he is really thanks so much for
watching if you're listening to this
and if you are please please please go
with jacqueline and i to go see whenever
greenland
2 comes out because we want you to do a
scene by scene breakdown
of how logical it actually is can we
spoil greenland
could i can i explore how do you do a
second one they're just what they're
they're building a new house
what is it they're building the world
they're figuring out what happened
is that a movie there may be some people
who survived
i think there's just going to be a
different like they get out and then
everybody's trying to kill remember that
movie um
not movie there was a tv show on fox
that cost way too much money and i don't
know why it ever got
a terra nova it's gonna be like terra
nova
yeah where like they blast that they're
trying to like start a new earth and
like a different that's what this is
going to be
terra no terra nova is one of those
shows like dynatopia where the only
reason i know it is because you could
just hear
joe buck's soul die when he has to
promote it during a football game
he's like tune in to a new it's harry we
gotta save the world
anyway third and eight troy what's that
prescott gonna do here
um that was a great uh question thank
you lucy for that i would totally sign
off on you being a high school science
teacher
and with that we are going to move on to
our next section which is mailbag and i
once again get to be
the little hairy stamper of this show
and say brian
conduct the music
[Music]
you can hit us up anytime rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com that's rt
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com we love
hearing your comments your questions and
particularly recommendations
for what movies we should be talking
about with future episodes that's
actually probably how we got armageddon
on this
program today so this is from our member
of the ketchup crew jeff
foxcroft what a cool that jeff foxcroft
sounds like a name
that you would hear in armageddon as
like one of the cool oil rig workers so
jeff if you work in oil
let us know jeff says hey y'all just got
my last
action hero 4k disk and was surprised it
only had a 40
rating from critics and a 47 score from
the audience wth
i remember it failing at the box office
but i personally love the movie and know
it has
its fans is it perfect not at all but
it's a fun subverses take
on the 1980s action hero genre and
rotten tomatoes is wrong on both fronts
in my opinion it's a misunderstood
underrated gem
please keep this movie in mind for
future shows
shout out to our austin gal jaclyn
love the show and keep up the good work
that is from jeff who is also
in austin surprisingly he's one of the
few non-comedians currently living in
austin
jack they're allowed i did not know that
that was currently illegal
in austin is to not tell jokes so i love
that call last action hero
juan harris you're our special guest
today 30 seconds
as to whether last action hero should be
higher than 40 percent on the tomato
meter
yeah once again rotten tomatoes
completely missing the boat on this one
i
i love last action i think it was before
it's time i think if you release
last action hero today everything's more
meta
people are more into the self-aware
post-post-modernist kind of take on
stuff
i think this could be a huge hit today i
actually pitched i think on movie fights
a
some of this is a prime remake
opportunity i think
to do a new version of this that
parodies like a john wick
style action franchise um so yeah i
think this one just suffered coming out
obviously around the same time as
jurassic park
and then just being ahead of its time
like uh
you know a shane black script before the
world was ready for
what shane black does it's good that
would be a fun episode jacqueline
i actually am about this uh i was
looking at the kid that was in here
because i was like i need to remember
exactly who the kid was in that because
that's
ryan yeah and i just have to say for
that one
shout out to my girl too i was like
that's what that kid is because he's
also in that one another underrated gym
um i'm with you on the on the last
action hero
but i'm also saying we should do the
last boy scout that's what i first
thought of when i thought of this movie
um shout out to jeff though um first of
all i have not been to austin
in years it's sad i'm gonna get to go
there very soon so
jeff please go have queso everywhere you
possibly can because i can just tell you
there's a severe case of deficiency
in california and it really breaks my
heart daily also
um i hope you're having fun at barton
springs because i am not
but i will be there soon shout out to
atx stand up
and brisket two of my favorite things
when i go to austin or you can get a
queso brisket
grilled cheese sandwich because they
have that too
just point me at the food truck and uh
and we're going um thank you jeff and
austin for that wonderful email again
you can email us anytime rt is wrong
at rottentomatoes.com juan harris it has
been an absolute treat to have you on a
show
for just about an hour and only have to
ask you one
movie trivia question yeah which is more
of a science trivia question than
anything
else um what is uh what what are you
working on tell me more about the
podcast you do with our good friend hal
rudnick
where can all the kids out there find
you yeah binge boys that's the podcast i
do without running we basically just
watch
a ton of streaming tv shows and films on
all the platforms
and then yak at each other about them do
some news you know
all the things that are going on on
streaming tv so it's a good way to keep
up with
what shows you need to watch and what's
coming back and what's happening on the
calendar
and also you know here get get some
chuckles from from hal and myself
having fun and and knocking that around
so that's on spotify
itunes basically anywhere you would go
to find your podcast selections and
listen to them
uh just search for binge boys not the
binge boys
there's another there's another group of
boys who binge with
their names so just binge boys okay i
smell an american gladiator style free
for all
yeah if only they would meet us in the
cage
and we could work this out like men in
the octagon but so far no luck
uh while you're doing all that stuff for
uh binge boys you can also do that for
us here at rotten tomatoes is wrong
wherever you enjoy your podcast
you can either subscribe or follow or
rate review
do all the fun stuff that they encourage
you to do because it helps us continue
to talk about movies lon cannot let you
get out of here before you give us some
sort of
streaming movie recommendation something
in theaters you like something that
is uh available to people in their homes
what is something that delon harris says
everybody out there needs to watch my
absolute favorite show
of this year so far i know a lot of
other people have already probably
recommended it to you i'm gonna add my
voice to the choir
hacks on hbo max with gene smart
uh the the funniest show that i've seen
this year
it has a lot of heart great characters
it's another one of those things we were
talking about this over again where
every role
is somebody funny there's no like
throwaway even if you only get like two
scenes in the whole season
they put somebody hilarious in the part
uh i really i really enjoyed it
but it's about stand up right and so i i
just get triggered
by shows about he's like uh it's like a
joan rivers-type
legendary vegas comedian she hires
hannah einbender who's this young
comedy writer who to come in and like
write jokes for her
i don't i i feel like it's a more
realistic
depiction of the world of comedy than
say punchline or some of the great
stand-up films
of history but who could say i'm not i'm
not a pro
so we need to have punchline we we need
to do an episode
i bet ryan tomatoes is right about
punchline unseen i bet you're right
whatever it's at it's probably right uh
jack when it was it was a fun one today
this was one that we've been looking
forward to for a long time and yes sir
you know we're not done and hopefully
we're never done talking about some of
the big blockbusters of your
on this here show what do we have in
store for the kids next week
all right kids next week we're actually
gonna do one that i feel the internet
has had
a lot to say about not as much as it's
as a preceding film but we're gonna be
breaking down is rotten tomatoes wrong
about
iron man 2 the one that gave us
scarlett johansson instead of emily
blunt
as black widow and i'm not saying that
that's a bad thing but i just wanted
everyone to know this is where it
happened
this is where it happened we got mickey
rourke and he was a big fan of birds and
there's a really cool scene
racing indy cars and a whole lot more we
also got don
cheadle replacing terence howard there's
going to be a lot to talk about
in this here movie so iron man 2 is next
week for
juan harris jacqueline coley producy
lucy
brian our engineer the entire
hard-working gang here behind the scenes
at rotten tomatoes i am merely mark
ellis you can see me
live in seattle july 24th you can get
tickets at mark ellis dot live
and until next week make sure you rate
subscribe
follow do all those things for the
podcast because you don't want to miss
a thing
[Music]
you